Yeah.
But Will Smith and the rock need to make a movie together?
They never have.
No.
That's to be the biggest movie in the history of knowing your history and they
blow outs.
Tom Cruise,
get them all together.
Tom Cruise will Smith and the,
you ever interview Tom Cruise?
Uh,
no,
but only with my brain.
When I'm in my sensory deprivation tank,
he reaches out to me.
Does he really make some MindMeld?
Yeah,
he puts on his,
uh,
Scientology earbuds.
Any,
uh,
astral traveling.
Say it's amazing.
Interview Time Cruise.
What's amazing about it?
It's because you hear so many different stories.
Do you wake up with your pants off?
No,
I didn't.
not,
not at that time.
Who am I?
Separateis base.
But he doesn't break eye contact with you.
[inaudible] that's what I like.
No,
he just like,
Hey,
what's up?
Yeah.
And what he'll do is I get nervous.
No,
I'm not.
no,
no.
But that's what he's doing.
He's basically nervous.
Well,
or he's just wants you to know he's,
he's locked in,
right?
Like he will not break eye contact.
Like,
if you look over,
he'd be like,
probably makes it harder for you ass fucked up questions to know what he does.
And I tell all my
what he does,
I tell all my friends when you interviewed Tom Cruise,
he will take,
ask him a question.
He'll try and make it three minutes long so he doesn't have,
you can't ask them that.
Maybe.
So you gotta learn,
you gotta build a relationship with them so then you can ask them a bunch.
See,
I've interviewed him so many times,
I'll walk it.
I remember one time I walked in the room and say,
Hey Tom,
I've got five minutes so we're going to have to answer these questions.
So I got to that point.
But he,
he's a great,
nice guy.
Did you ever get the Scientology?
No.
Never.
Is that part of the deal?
You can't ask him about that?
Well,
I heard a part of Scientology is for you to walk out the room saying how great
they are and I just did since I just did it.
Right.
Yeah.
So maybe yes it did.
It's just,
that's just a philosophy on like how to influence people.
Positively influence people.
You want those people really thinking the best of you.
Good strategy.
Well,
everybody was like,
oh,
he's crazy as this is that every time I interviewed,
he's great.
I love,
I mean,
I love Tom Cruise.
Some of my favorite people are crazy.
Yeah.
Tell me someone's crazy.
That doesn't shake me.
I'm not like,
okay,
well talk to them.
They're crazy.
My favorite people are all crazy.
Yeah.
Like literally crazy.
My favorite people.
So for someone tells me that someone's crazy.
I'm like,
okay,
what else?
You got crazy not scary to me.
Like will Smith is awesome.
He's got to be crazy.
Will Smith.
Sure.
No.
Oh No.
We're going on two nights,
two nights too smart.
No mercy.
No scientologist.
I have no idea.